That's got going with John Stuart Mill.
And let me just one more time to say,
John Stuart Mill is formidably influential,
very influential on our days,
and he's the ultimate of liberalism.
And I'm in some days,
uh,
among all the auteurist video be reading this semester,
he's the most consistent,
uh,
the clearest one and the most consistent of the mall.
Uh,
he draws the line to the logical conclusions,
uh,
no matter what it is,
right.
Um,
and,
you know,
taking just point of departure from Adam Smith's lock,
Adam Smith's and then,
um,
Bantam,
uh,
he pushes the line of utilitarianism to its most logical conclusions and he's
extremely influential what we call now neoclassical economics.
And he's fine.
He was exactly the person who made the many people who've are liberals and
Democrats in the 1960s and seventies to change and create what they call,
they'll conservative is more narrowly,
but all his Ma and went over to the Republican Party was an important dividing
line,
um,
uh,
meals,
a strong insistence on individual liberty.
Right.
And He,
and what follows from this staunch insistence,
uh,
for,
the role of the state.
Right?
And how far stage can interfere,
uh,
individuals.
Uh,
that was really,
I think the dividing line in which many people who were on the political left
center left or occasionally far left,
uh,
by the late 1960s,
early seventies,
seeing stuff like the affirmative action,
the war on poverty,
they change their lines.
They said,
look,
the Democratic Party liberal is Maria.
He betrays liberal is that's not liberalism.
Readjust to earth meal.
That's when you've,
or UV or Nova three or liberalism is right.
Anyway,
so I think this is,
this is why he,
you know,
his message is very much alive and I'm sure that,
um,
uh,
this classroom is divided by people.
You know,
some people subscribe to a John Stewart meals,
a reburial asthma.
Others probably do think that he emphasizes too much individual liberties and
that is much more of a role to implement the general God by the government.
Okay.
I mean,
I think we left it right here.
Um,
uh,
last week.
These are the main team of utilitarian.
He's book on Utilitarianism,
the way how he departs from Bantam,
um,
very important change,
uh,
that he,
beginning to emphasize that our higher happiness is because we can see it is not
simply quantity,
but quality of happiness is what we see.
Very important contribution,
I think.
And this is an idea which is a only touched upon by Adam Smith's buttery or
they're not properly developed and certainly completely missing the in Bantam.
Uh,
it is really mirror contribution,
which is very important for a contemporary,
uh,
economic theory.
No,
no classical economics.
They call this preferences,
right?
That we have preferences and therefore individuals will attach different values
to different utilities.
Right?
Um,
and this really comes from the version of John Stuart Mill.
Then,
you know,
he makes this distinction between legality and,
uh,
justice.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
what is legal is not necessarily just and what is justice necessarily approved
by laws.
Um,
and then justice and expediency but is expedient,
is not necessarily just,
um,
uh,
and,
we are just may have you Scott and me and I'd be the fastest way to get that
right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
Libor our way through of this and leave time to look at the questions there.
The idea is that we are human beings and therefore we have capacity to have a,
uh,
higher appetites then the animal appetites,
right?
Um,
so we have imagination about animals don't have,
we have moral sentiments and these moral sentiments may lead us in our choices.
Right now you can see,
uh,
the,
the met I mentioned that about Adam Smith.
Adam Smith might have had this theory of sympathetic humans,
uh,
which,
you know,
v born did these deduction.
This is very central for John John Stewart to male.
Uh,
and therefore he emphasizes that is a qualitative difference,
right between human and simply animal appetites.
Uh,
so therefore you simply cannot do what Bantam did.
Simply add up,
right?
The epithets and to save more appetites are satisfied.
Better of the society is,
uh,
the chief good.
So he argues is virtual be virtuous and then you'll,
you'll feel good.
You'll be,
we'll be happier if you are virtuous,
uh,
such,
Bart,
you know,
these are all qualifications of the kind of elementary utilitarian is my thing.
Qualifications.
But by the way,
a more stringent or choice your and uh,
and now classic classical economist,
if you'll also aggravate,
uh,
those who are critiques of now liberals and utilitarianism very often kind of
caricature that position mark reality,
understanding that following John's you are new.
They do understand that there is a qualitative differences between utilities,
but otherwise he remains by the utilitarian principle.
We are rational actors.
The ourself interested,
we know of what our needs are and we can make good judgments,
right?
Whether the price we have to pay in order to satisfy our needs is various for
us,
right?
That is the fundamental right idea of utilitarianism,
uh,
which is,
thank you very healthy today that are many people who disagree with it.
There are many people who agree with it.
All right?
Um,
but this is all,
uh,
John Stuart Mills,
um,
uh,
addition and now a bit on higher happiness.
Well,
the pleasure of the beast.
My be felt as decorating by a human being.
Um,
uh,
all right.
We want to have some,
we have higher needs than just,
uh,
um,
the animal needs civil,
or you'll go to a five star restaurant.
Maybe you serve you a little rude,
right?
It'll be delicious,
but it will be unlike,
you know,
these Italian family restaurant down the road.
And I in the Wooster street where they give you,
right,
um,
food,
what you can hardly eat,
right?
We satisfies your animal advertise,
So anyway,
we have higher needs,
higher appetize,
right?
We want to see it or food served in a special way,
And the honor just don't feed our belly as such.
And there are,
you know,
uh,
the pleasures of the Internet and imagination.
I think we all ready have seen,
listen also how important imagination is.
And if you are in comparative literature or English,
you know,
of course the aesthetic theories of,
um,
uh,
Schiller,
the German poet,
right?
Uh,
who emphasized how important actually,
um,
Eh,
uh,
imagination and play is in figuring out what,
what beauty is.
What are this do is something like,
Eh,
all right.
Um,
and then a bit on quality of life measures.
Right?
The reality,
the question is what kind of pleasure satisfies us rather than just the
quantity.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
I think this is,
this is a very powerful point.
Uh,
uh,
a few women's,
would to be changed into Annie of the lower animals.
Um,
right?
Uh,
uh,
no intelligent being would go on sand to be a fool even though they should be
persuaded that a fool is better satisfied then a lot of man,
right?
It's easier to satisfy occasionally Fu and this is really beautiful.
It's better to be a human being,
be satisfied then a big satisfied,
right.
Better to be so Kratos this satisfied then a full satisfied Bingo.
Right.
He got it.
I think that's very guilty,
fully done.
Powerfully done.
Think about it.
Very hard to disagree with this.
Right?
You want to be right,
Socrates.
Right.
And this satisfied rather than just being satisfied by your needs.
Well,
I don't want to develop,
go march on the issue of justice and the legalities,
quite obvious,
right?
That there are differences between justice and illegality.
Illegality.
Now it is unjust if anybody's a deprived from his personal liberty or,
or property,
uh,
um,
even if,
if that's what the law tells you.
I mean,
come on.
These government confiscated property from people and they did it legally.
But,
uh,
John Stuart Mill,
you say they did it on just the right,
it was legally done,
but unjustly.
Uh,
it was against the sense of justice of people are being deprived around the
travesty and that are laws which do not exist at all.
They should exist,
right?
Um,
because some of the individual rights are not properly defended and you really
should have a such laws.
And of course for him,
uh,
there has not been in his time sufficient laws to protect the rights of women or
the rise of sleep.
So,
um,
they'll also,
today we are concerned about whether we have dropped our production in this
country for individual liberties against the,
uh,
surveillance techniques,
for instance,
which were used,
right.
Uh,
very recently in the United States.
Many people think we need very stricter controls on the government where there
they can listen to our telephone conversations,
right?
The want to have very clear laws rightly should define exactly what torture is.
We may be uncertain,
but the laws are sufficiently clear,
right?
So therefore you need occasionally laws which protects,
uh,
human rights.
This argument can be used actually for affirmative action.
I do.
You may need occasionally laws,
which kind of eliminates the inequalities,
right?
Of People's three dorms is some people have less freedom,
others because they've have it full can start from a different starting point.
Then you can use John Stuart mill argument and to say you need a law which we
protect these people and make sure that they are three enough,
right?
That they are there.
They,
you create an equality of freedom.
That would be his argument.
And then our laws which exist,
but they should not exist that are bad and aren't just laws.
Uh,
well we debate this issue a great deal.
uh,
I'm sure there are some people in this country who do think that the government
should not kill,
right?
There are some people who are against the death penalty.
Probably the majority's forward that specialty,
but there is probably a minority in this room.
I don't want to ask you to show hands,
do I mind?
But I'm sure there are some people who think the government should or should not
kill people.
I'm one of those.
I don't think that's right.
I think life is sacred.
I believe sufficiently,
um,
uh,
in hops,
first law of nature.
No government should here.
Uh,
so that's penalty.
I don't think it's right,
but you can't argue it's,
it's necessary to defend other people's freedom.
Right?
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think,
John Stuart mill probably would have been unhappy with the desk panel.
Uh,
so,
uh,
um,
you may want to change legislation,
right?
You may want to have a legislation,
right,
which are,
eliminates the death penalty or you know,
and other issuers,
let's say,
uh,
again,
I'm sure this audience here is divided on the question of,
uh,
abortion that are some people who've believed that,
you know,
abortion should be prohibited by law because you should defend the freedom and
right of existence of the unborn child that are others.
Why are you the freedom argument on the other side,
right?
They say,
no,
you should not prohibit abortion because you should defend liberty of the women
who carries the child.
All right?
Now this,
these are just examples,
right?
That these issues are talking to very contemporary issues,
alright?
Uh,
justice and the equality.
This is a very interesting,
uh,
idea of what he's playing.
Get Out.
He said the head have actual year sense that justice is somehow related to
equality.
That we occasionally feel that some degree of inequality is already on.
Just even if it is legally achieved by legal means,
we may see it is unjust,
usual,
all the inequalities are,
uh,
um,
explained and justified by expediency,
right?
You have to create these high levels of inequality because you have to create
incentives.
We just heard this debate,
you know,
the last couple of weeks.
Um,
if you try to limit the bonuses,
the guys on Wall Street,
you get,
you do a lot of damage because this hot,
you know,
brokers will be hired by the competition.
Therefore they have to get this hundred million dollar bonuses.
Otherwise the business will be heard,
right?
And there were banks which were paying bank millions of dollars to the federal
government.
So the federal government cannot intervene,
right?
And cannot overrule,
How much bonus is they?
Right.
Expediency,
right?
They say,
oh,
give me a break about these justice stuff,
that this is unfair that somebody earns $100 million they should learn because
otherwise the competition gets them.
Right.
Now,
this is the argument of experience.
See not the argument of justice,
right?
Uh,
all right.
well,
there are different components of justice.
Well,
the first and most important one,
it is unjust to deprive anyone of its personal liberty and property.
That's the most important point,
right?
In just you Stuart near,
he's actually defending individual liberty.
The second one illegal,
right,
uh,
is deprived maybe rights,
which ought not to have belonged to him,
right?
That may be privileges.
I mean,
in contemporary societies,
this is much less common in his time that read a lot of laws that I featured.
The fact that the bended defended people's privileges,
fueled our privileges,
but he wanted to get rid off.
Right?
Um,
Dave or unjust.
Well,
he also then suggest that each person should obtain bought he or she deserves.
Right?
Even if it is not guaranteed by law.
Well,
how far do you go with this argument?
It's again,
can be very controversial.
Uh,
you can say that now you need a welfare state,
right?
Are you have to provide the basic goods and services?
What everybody,
uh,
you know,
this argument can be used,
you have to provide housing.
You should not let anybody in the south shelter,
um,
uh,
or you should not let anybody,
if you south health scare,
uh,
that would be consistent with John Stuart Mill.
And then he said,
well,
uh,
it is unjust.
If you bake faith,
right?
You promised somebody,
either you do it and then you take your bird back that's unjust at that.
You should not do that.
Um,
uh,
and it's fine,
or this is very important,
right?
Justice cannot be partial,
Uh,
it has to be blind,
right?
And has to be equal to all parties.
And now,
uh,
justice had expediency.
I again,
don't want to labor on this.
This is obvious,
right?
That's what is expedient is not necessarily just expedient,
is if you reach that goal with minimum effort,
but occasionally you don't,
you,
you better not make shortcuts making those shortcuts maybe unjust and unfair.
And then of course,
sympathy,
right?
Uh,
we are all capable to sympathize,
uh,
not only,
with people we know about with the whole humankind.
We have sympathy,
um,
uh,
sympathy for our country and our mankind.
It's a bit,
you know,
like Rousseau's Lamore dropper,
uh,
idea.
Um,
uh,
I think I probably skipped this one.
Uh,
uh,
I think,
we,
it's quite obvious.
You know why,
uh,
justice and expediency do have a complicated
relationship.
And now on the other book on liberty,
right?
Well,
uh,
by them only emphasize,
that we are seeking pleasure mill emphasize self development,
right?
Uh,
he said,
uh,
we have to in our lifetime we have to develop our capacities,
right?
Um,
uh,
and what follows from this individual is and liberty,
these are the major values,
right?
Rather than just satisfying our needs.
Well,
this is an extremely important idea and very much an idea of John Stuart Mill.
We should not take freedom as uh,
as granted.
And he said,
be very careful of rulers,
right?
Who identify with the people.
It does not guarantee freedom,
right?
Because it can lead to the tyranny of the majority.
You have to defend the rights of the individuals,
the rights of the minorities,
that they should be also free to choose.
This falls very logically from his argument,
right?
Of these higher happinesses preferences arrived at by individual judgments,
Not Super Imposed by government,
but individuals decide.
But is that higher value they attach to our utility?
Uh,
and therefore,
you know,
it can be minorities which do have different preferences and they have to
respect those references.
That's very cool,
shall important ideas.
And that unit individual liberties should overstay precedents over short term
utilitarian consideration,
right?
The main value is individual liberty.
And believe me,
this is not a contradiction.
It follows very logically from the idea of preferences and from the idea that
there are qualitative differences between utilities and you are the only one who
can decide what is verse for you.
Mobile as scan naked,
a decision and judgment for you.
This is consistent with Adam Smith's by the way.
And then freedom of expression that is no nobody whom VB or read,
who stands so strongly for freedom of expression,
complete unlimited freedom of expression.
Um,
and the United States comes very close,
right to this and this is the only country in the dish comes so close to it.
In other countries which are democratic,
free and liberal freedom of speech may be limited.
You know,
he speech might,
may be actually limited,
right?
Denying the Holocaust and you end up in jail in Germany.
Right?
Um,
but,
uh,
in the US,
we,
we are very close to the million idea and he said,
this is absolutely natural set read to have that total freedom of speech because
an opinion,
uh,
Digi supressive right?
Then they lose the opportunity to exchange throughs for error.
So therefore it's obvious that it's noncontroversial,
right.
The truce even it is unpleasant,
should be lot to this poker.
Right?
Uh,
what is more problematic?
should we are low to people to speak falsehood.
I mean,
we know right,
that the Holocaust existed,
right?
Should Vlo uh,
those crazy people to tell us against all this strong evidence what we have then
there was no holocaust.
He argues,
yes,
we should because this is the only day how they can find out the error if we
talk about this.
So very controversial argument.
As I said,
there are many countries in this word bitch do subscribe to it.
Right?
Um,
so,
and he said they have to listen to both sides.
That's the only way how we find out what truth is and tyranny by the majority.
Well,
this is very,
very important.
Our humanity,
right?
Uh,
uh,
namely.
Okay.
One of the main major evils of a mass democratic society is a tyranny of the
majority.
That will be a very strong tendency to suppress dissent and to conformity with
the majority views.
And he said,
well,
uh,
we have to try to resist it and we have to emphasize individuality.
Uh,
go on a forum is,
is more or oppression,
right?
There's a lot of pressure on you to conform,
uh,
be the major,
the main stream as such.
And he said,
this is one of the big evs what we have to resist and we have to defend the
individual liberties,
right?
And we have to,
uh,
fight against intervention,
legal or not legal intervention,
right?
He did not live in a mass communication.
So Sadie,
but he would have been outraged,
you know,
how the media tries to brain wash people and write and put it into a,
conform his behavior on people,
right?
Uh,
he wanted the fen people's individual choices of life size and sexual
preferences and whatever you name,
you know,
it has to be defended a,
and this is very important,
right?
This is uh,
uh,
a clear extension,
very clearly argued.
Adam Smith did,
did basically agree with this,
but he did not look at sure strongly.
And so clearly,
therefore,
intervention by a government is only permissible if injury has been taken place,
right?
Brace.
Uh,
the government cannot limit individual liberties only if that causes injury.
And he said,
look,
believe me,
I'm not indifferent.
I am for compassion.
All of that guy I am asking you is stolen guns,
respect other people's choices,
right?
No,
Theo compassion,
but don't try to make decisions for others.
Don't impose your will on others.
That's,
I think that and conformity,
right?
He is really this slide conformity.
It's essentially ahead of his son.
This becomes a very big issue in the 1960s and seventies,
that conformism is an evil and he already writes about this.
Um,
in the mid 19th century ended well,
interference can be only have,
the only justification is self protection,
right?
Uh,
uh,
now this is very much in line of,
of hops argument.
Um,
and therefore he said,
right,
I'm not for indifference,
but I am for permissiveness,
for tolerances.
Sorry.
Um,
uh,
well of you should help each other and,
but there's different than to impose our will or our taste or our preferences on
other people,
right?
Uh,
uh,
neither [inaudible] person nor any number of person is warranted the insane to
other human creatures of Rye peers.
That's different with children,
um,
that he shell and not to do it his life for his own benefit,
but he chooses to do with it right now.
A very strong argument and very troubling.
You know,
it's a,
what do you think about drug use,
right?
A bell.
If a John Stuart mill air,
he errs on the libertarian side,
he probably would be arguing for the decriminalization of most of the drugs.
Um,
uh,
on these ground,
you know,
this people's choice if they know that they heard the life.
This is that story now,
a very briefly and his views on,
on the man,
and I don't have to introduce you to the background,
you know,
that it mid 19th century,
uh,
women did not have equal rights.
Even not in England,
not in the United States.
They not only did not have the right to vote,
uh,
but they actually did not have the right to own property as such.
Um,
uh,
well,
as I mentioned how the,
uh,
Taylor,
um,
uh,
his lover and viper was a radical feminist as far as we know,
an extremely smart woman.
Uh,
she was more that he called and smiths because she actually,
so I pointed out,
um,
uh,
oppose even,
the institution of marriage.
So what are the major teams in this book?
The first point is,
um,
marriage is the only remaining case of slavery.
Uh,
well it's not true.
Of course,
leave already has as it existed as fat and unfortunately the factors still exist
around the world.
But he said,
you know,
uh,
the subject,
subjugation of women is a case of slavery and it cannot be explained by the
nature of women.
And he makes a case for it.
And he aren't used for legal equality and marriage and equality of women in
politics and education and all the mixer case for marital friendship.
So,
um,
and you said managers,
the only remaining example of slavery,
uh,
because they cannot own property,
and,
uh,
in fact,
their husbands can use them for sexual desires.
So in this sense it is even worse than slavery.
At least the sleeves are not expected,
right?
To love their slave owners.
Uh,
the vives I'd expected to love their husbands.
So he said this is even worse than slavery.
Right?
Uh,
and here he kind of elaborates on this issue,
right?
Uh,
at this,
uh,
not simply the obedience what man wants,
but also that they're lava.
And usually,
you know,
these relationships very early in the 19th century,
and in many cases,
even in the 21st century,
asymmetric.
All right.
A man probably does not feel as much obliged to express love towards the vives
than they expect that of wives to express loft overdone.
That.
Right?
Well,
unfortunately,
I think that our steel meant like this.
Okay.
Um,
so that's,
uh,
I think a very provocative,
very important statements written in the mid 19th century now.
And then he said,
this cannot be explained by the nature of women.
Uh,
uh,
he expects you counter argument,
well,
different,
you know,
the rule and argument.
We men are different.
They want to knit,
you know,
they want to be subjugated.
He said no,
there are two counter arguments.
One is that we don't know about the nature of the MNR,
right?
Because they did not have a chance for self development.
Right?
And then he said,
in order to justify women step be mation,
you should be able to show that no woman would ever capable to occupy a certain
position.
So political authority,
if that were the man who did that,
then it cannot come from the nature women.
Right.
That's a neat argument.
Uh,
well he is the citation,
you know,
um,
how would we know,
right?
What the nature of the women is.
All right.
Um,
uh,
therefore this is an invalid argument.
He argues for the equality,
equality for marriage,
and that's,
do they,
it's a kind of common sensical,
Eh,
it doesn't need any further elaboration and equality of women in politics and
education and jobs.
This is still a very important,
and that is summer.
Uh,
the president of Harvard grab has not rat he John Stewart and you're carefully
enough.
Then he said,
right,
that's women and just not good enough,
right to do engineering.
Right.
He should have read John Stuart Mill and he should have known that there is
nothing in the nature of the men by they would not do as well in engineering
guys.
Man would,
uh,
sort of,
um,
and you know,
you know,
we still need some attention to diversity means diversity in order to make sure
that women do end up in political and other jobs.
And then he makes a case for marital friendship.
He said,
well,
I still believe in marriage because marriage can be based on equality of
partners.
So this is John Stuart Mill.
I hope you enjoy him.
I think he is a,
a controversial person,
pushes his point as far as as it can,
but I think is a very smart,
smart person.
Um,
so let me just,
uh,
I have,
two half more minutes to go and look at the questions and make a few comments.
How I would try to,
um,
uh,
myself deal via,
these,
uh,
questions in answering if I were in your shoes.
Uh,
okay.
And here we go.
Huh?
Let me see how far I can go.
Okay.
Uh,
so,
uh,
fresh out number one,
the first point,
what I would try to make here is that are people who read hops as believing that
humans are easier by nature.
This is not unreasonable after all vie owners.
You need la vie aton unless there is something wrong with us.
A while can also save l a walk,
which a lot of emphasis how rational the R and a state of nature and it will
show is explicit about his noble savage idea,
right?
It is society.
Which workshops have you all come out perfect from the hands of the Creator and
then Sasha screws us.
So that does seem to be really an argument here.
Uh,
uh,
well,
would I tried to say to [inaudible] that that is a controversy fell.
I may try to qualify it in a sentence or two.
That's all of course hops.
Good be ad in a more complex way.
Uh,
because,
uh,
um,
after it all harps also believes that we are making rational decisions,
van VR sort of edge adjudicating between our desires and our fears and the come
to a rational decision about this.
Um,
uh,
therefore it's not that obvious that this is maybe about,
I would say this is a qualification that is still one can see a controversy bell
who saw,
yes,
he states that Vr,
um,
uh,
you know,
come off perfect from the hands of God,
but off the road in the state of nature,
we are savages,
right?
Um,
and therefore we need to some General Ville,
right?
To overrule our judgment.
So that is some qualification how much they to Zahra Jacques had in us,
right?
[inaudible] had a bit suspicious of us.
So on,
these are the kinds of footnotes,
you know,
qualifications to the argument.
But then I would love if I,
what I will do,
I will say,
well,
I am a bit too romantic but to think about it because I do know that people can
be White Eliel right?
And therefore we do need more law and order.
Right.
We know need some intervention.
On the other hand,
I think I am probably more inclined,
I have to air to air on the side of Rousseau or John Stuart Mill.
Don't believe that people are after row after row.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
VL act out of good veal and therefore I would like to see less of central
planners telling me,
but I should be doing and what my needs are.
And I would better live in a society where individuals can decide and make the,
make the have three choices.
That would be my line.
But you could argue the other way around.
Right?
Tell us what your view is.
Anyway,
that's the way how I view the,
the,
this Gresh
that's I think quite clear.
Uh,
hops.
Bill believed in a strong and clearly identifiable silver and easy to support it
to be taxed.
I think this is uncontroversial and it's also quite clear that block wanted to
limit the power of the executive.
That's why he was to separate the executive right from the legislative.
So I did that.
And comparing them is,
is now pretty controversial.
You don't have to have many qualifications.
Do this right?
That's my straight forward now.
And what do you think right now?
What is your view on this?
Uh,
uh,
and you may say,
well,
uh,
hops has got a lot to say.
Think about the
September 11,
nine,
11.
Right now you need a strong government,
right?
If you need security,
We just cannot push too far for equality or you can't take the opposite
argument.
He said,
well I think all that happened after nine 11 was wrong.
We should not have limited,
you know,
individual liberties.
That's the American today that you send by Liberty.
Anyway,
I'm sure people are divided on this and I would like to hear your views on this.
That's a hard question to answer.
Uh,
in fact it is also a question who is a methodological individualist and
collectivist?
I would say a metal Dorjee got collectivist,
argues that there is stuff which is more than the sum total of individual Monty
skews.
Emphasis on law is a very good one,
right?
That the law,
you cannot explain the law by looking at,
at each individual and,
and the top.
And that's the law.
The law is there and then it enters the individuals,
right?
So there is a collective conscience.
Bish precedes the individual and enters the individuals and others like hearts
or lock,
I'll use the other way.
No,
they have to start with the individual.
The only thing,
but we can observe,
right,
is the individual action and desires and bill and then we can arrive at the call
activity,
right?
Well,
I'm not so sure whether you are the methodological individualists store now,
but you can actually make a case whether you really think,
whether the right way is to think about the individual's action and individuals
rather about the collective good,
right?
Which comes from something somewhere else.
More historic trolley.
Uh,
uh,
those,
those general veal make a strong case for it.
Easy to make,
right?
That is obviously something what is necessary for a gender role bill.
Uh,
you want to believe,
for instance,
um,
and uh,
uh,
universal,
house care and to say,
well,
it's,
this should not be let to individuals to decide whether they take out the house
insurance or not.
Everybody should be insured,
right?
It's easy to see,
Let's not fool us around,
right?
We need and a general bill.
So I think an argument can be made.
Um,
but then you can use,
uh,
a law or Montesquieu or meal or whomever to say,
well that is troubled with this argument of Arrow on ers.
The genital,
the is coming from a life,
you know,
methodological individual.
It's usually that save.
What about methodological collectivist there?
Do you know what it is right there?
Does it come from?
If it is not in any individual consciousness,
right?
So there,
you know,
how,
how do government know?
What is my need?
Did they get a letter telling them what my needs are and overrule my decision
because I think this is my need and my preference,
right?
So that can be devastating.
And you can say,
well,
this opens up the door to totalitarianism,
right?
That's why you know,
Karl Marx loved Raj.
Aclu saw so much.
That's why learning loved John Jacques Rousseau so much because they want that
to have the central planners,
which tell you this is your need.
You don't,
you know,
all your,
you'll short term needs.
I know you long term needs and therefore you have to do what I tell you you to
do.
Right?
And it also does that,
right?
He said you have to be forced to be three,
I can't let you two just to be free.
I have to tell you what you real freedom is what your real needs are and you can
be critical about this.
So you see,
you can make the point in both direction.
I think most are respectable positions.
Now,
Adam Smith's or pseudo self interests,
you achieved the common goods.
Many of you believe in this,
right?
Uh,
that's half three unregulated markets and there it will be ended up did the
collective good.
Uh,
but you know,
it was so beliefs in the General Ville,
which is more than the sum total of individuals.
Yeah,
you can contrast it so that it's similar to the previous question,
right?
Uh,
and you can make a case,
you know,
why you think Adam's Mrs,
right?
Uh,
you know,
very,
very nervous.
You'll be able to figure it out.
But these are,
unless people decide for themselves or you can say,
well,
Adam Smith's is not living in the real world because he assumes,
right,
perfect at self regulating markets and perfect in formations and none of those
exist.
So in Indonesia over that I'm Smith's does not,
does not apply.
And in the real world,
he actually,
uh,
John Jacques Rousseau,
it makes much more sense.
Now again,
you'll call how you make your decision about this.
Um,
you know,
strong government buy hops and Smith's Sir is uh,
uh,
about invisible hand as little government as possible.
Again,
I don't think I have to have that,
but eight on this,
you can see the line of argument,
easy to show that hops in beach suit for strong government.
You have the citation Adam Smith for the invisible hand.
You can add the footnote that is a controversy about this.
But most people today in the 21st century interpreted them smiths as the person
of invisible hand and small government.
And then you can say,
what is your view?
And again,
I think this class must be,
we have split 50,
50%.
Some people still believe,
you know,
Ronald Regan,
the government is not the solution.
The government is the problem.
Other people believe in,
you know,
uh,
Liberal Democrats and you're saying,
no,
no.
We need big government.
And just see what happened.
Now in the global financial crises then there was not enough government and was
too much deregulation.
We need regulation and just see about George W.
Bush did,
right?
He bailed out from taxpayers money.
Anyway,
you see the point,
right?
What you can do,
you can argue it both ways.
Well,
the agenda issue.
Ah,
AH,
wow.
Hard to defend Russo,
right?
Uh,
he really sucks
that lead team carefully.
I gave you the citations.
He said,
well,
uh,
he's foreshadows the idea of distinction between sex and gender.
He says,
well,
can see he's a sophisticated feminist.
He said the man should not look like man.
They have equally humans.
They have same human rights,
but it would be wrong for the men to dress like Matt,
right?
What's wrong about a woman being feminine?
There are some contemporary feminist who are you this way?
So don't dismiss him too easy.
Well meal,
I don't think needs to much of the fence for four,
five minutes though.
I could offer some criticism,
feminists,
criticism of him.
Now I'll bill it was a utilitarian,
um,
uh,
well what is his difference between Adam Smith's?
Uh,
well this is a hard question to ask.
That is not that much difference,
but as I was trying to point out in the lecture today,
that is a difference,
right?
Uh,
John Stuart Mill is much more conscious about preferences and the qualitative
differences we attached to different utilities.
The idea is not something,
but Adam Smith's would both school,
but certainly an idea which has not been as elaborately developed in Adam
Smith's than it was in John Stewart mill.
Uh,
this is very easy,
right?
Again,
harps,
arguing for security and the meal or lock arguing for freedom.
Uh,
you can make the case.
We have done it in earlier,
uh,
questions.
Uh,
um,
and you can tell,
tell loss.
What do you think again,
I think the room VOB split bill,
you want to allow people to carry guns?
Some people think yes.
What individual?
The other of you say,
this is crazy.
Most countries in the world who don't tell all week and just see these nuts,
right?
Keep mess murdering people in schools.
Of course they do.
If they can carry guns and nine 11,
right?
Thor?
Sure.
Uh,
this listening to people's telephone conversations,
some people will,
they'll say,
oh,
well,
we are living in a dangerous world.
We should their load the CIA to do that,
right?
Honestly will say,
no,
no.
Individually,
liberty are sacrosanct.
Right?
And this is what I would like to hear from you.
Okay.
Have Fun.
And Bees do enjoy it,
right?
It's not regurgitating this exercises about thinking.